the new attention on the mag of
republicans you tweeted in 2017
i was waiting peter when you were going
to ask me that question well here we go
you tweeted trump stolen election you
tweeted brian kemp stole an election if
denying election results
is extreme now yeah
so let's let's be really clear that
that comparison that you made is just
ridiculous i have been i have been well
you're asking me you're asking me a
question let me answer it and you said
ridiculous i was i was talking
specifically at that time of what was
happening with voting rights and the
what was in danger of voting rights
that's what i was speaking to at the
time
how you doing people i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report it's september 7th
2022 and that was noted black lesbian
press secretary corinne jean-pierre
exercising the one privilege that
actually does exist in the united states
democrat privilege because when you're a
democrat you can
claim that elections are fixed you can
claim that violence is not violence all
of those things and you can get away
with it uh and we thought that would
just be a fun little way to start the
show today because it sort of sets the
theme that i want to talk about today
which really is about censorship because
uh you know we can do the day-to-day
stuff we can
open up the computer machine in our
pocket every day and pick the stories
for the day and figure out what's
important to talk about and all of those
things
but
without being able to see what's really
going on uh it can get very difficult to
do that and it's very obvious that it's
getting harder and harder to see what
actually is going on whether it is media
outright lies related to say brett
kavanaugh is a serial uh rapist or kyle
rittenhouse is a racist or the jesse
smallett hoax or very fine people on
both sides or the hunter biden laptop
whether we see it or we don't or
the vaccines are gonna
stop covid all of the stuff that we know
either is not true or is half true or
they promote or they suppress uh it all
sits
on this sort of uh this table basically
of whether or not we can see things and
it seems like at this point we are being
censored
in in crazy ways i can tell you and this
is why i want to do the show this way uh
today is that it's very very obvious
that all of my accounts are being hit
big time right now twitter is just
absolutely useless i'm being shadow
banded to oblivion i post and i can
actually watch people's comments
disappear when they respond to me uh
youtube i'm being told constantly by
people and in the comment section that
if you are subscribed and you have the
notification bell clicked you are not
seeing our videos uh we know that the
recommended videos are sending you to
all sorts of things if you search my
name it sends you to videos of people
that hate me all kinds of crazy stuff
and this is just it just is what it is
i'm actually not doing this show today
to complain about this stuff i'm doing
this show to point out a problem and
then go to where the solutions are and i
think that they're actually our
solutions so what really inspired this
show was that a couple days ago
my buddy
brian callan uh was on joe rogan's show
and they started talking about what's
going on with some of the censorship
stuff and obviously rogan has been right
in the middle of the censorship
censorship fight and they started
talking about rumble so uh let's take a
look i would i would go over there
though bring everything if if they got
big enough i think they i think because
they offer tim dillon too right i think
they're doing some with russell brand or
they're trying to what is rumble who
started it i love russell brand i'm not
exactly who started it um
not exactly sure i know dave rubin's
part of it but i i don't know exactly
he's coming he's coming back
they're starting to do some stuff where
they're getting bigger and bigger names
and if they do that and it becomes
popular enough and they can operate the
way they're doing it right now with no
censorship
it's very it's a very interesting so
quick yeah rumble overnight could
yeah overnight i have eight shows you
know not bad i would move all my [ __ ]
there if it was worth it i think you
move move just
have another have it there too you know
what i mean and the problem is like it's
not
widespread with a lot of people yet but
if someone big went over there like
think about how many people russell
brand has if russell brand i think he's
got like six million youtube followers
now if he goes over there i mean he's
he's already giant starts an influx and
he goes over there and everyone knows
and they just go to rumble it's just a
different click you have to do it's not
that big people are just loyal they get
youtube they're not loyal rumble rumbles
basically like youtube but they don't
censor people and they don't cancel
that's what i know is that all it is
it's essentially they're they're they're
committed to having a free speech
platform the problem with that is when
people hear that they go oh right wing
oh you're a magazine board like
immediately think that you're right but
no tulsi gabbard's over there glenn
greenwald is over there dude
okay so rogan basically captures what's
going on here i did not show that
because he mentions me i'm not even
totally sure if he is aware of exactly
what i've done with rumble obviously i
started locals which merged with rumble
and we are fighting for free speech when
i when i sat down and had a bunch of the
meetings uh when me and the locals
people sat down and had the meetings uh
with chris who's the ceo of rumble and
we discussed whether we could do this
and why it would make sense and what the
risks would be uh and obviously dan
bongino is well as big in in the rumble
world as well we sat down with all these
guys and what were our policies around
speech going to be in all of these
things we basically said it was going to
be a neutral platform and that was the
purpose of why we did the merger and how
uh that's our philosophy related to
free speech and what people can and
can't say right you can't you can't
threaten to kill somebody you've got a
bigger problem than rumble or youtube or
anything else you got a problem with the
laws of the united states
anyway it is good to see that people are
starting to realize right like joe rogan
if he's anything he's sort of like the
voice of the people right like i don't
think he garners him or he furnishes
himself as like an expert in anything
particularly maybe in mma fighting but
he's sort of like the voice of the
people and the people are realizing the
censorship stuff is crashing down he
also said something interesting there at
the end that whenever
you do something that is standing up for
free speech or whenever you defend the
people who are being cancelled you're
automatically called right wing i was
glad to hear him say that tulsi
gabbard's on there and glenn greenwald
and people who clearly are not right now
why
did this whole thing pop up on rogan's
radar well a guy by the name of andrew
tate who i had never heard of until a
couple weeks ago he's a big uh british
kickboxer uh who has sort of become like
a i don't know like a bit of a younger
this is going to be a crazy comparison
at some level but like a younger jordan
peterson in that he's talking to young
men about getting their lives in order
uh he's garnered millions and millions
of views he's huge across everything
well basically about two weeks ago he
was canceled everywhere youtube took
them out facebook took them out
instagram took him out tick tock took
him out everyone took this guy out and
of course when they do a coordinated
assassin assassination like that you
know something's up it's like is this
guy really a hater is he teaching people
to hate women is he teaching people to
be terrorists or be really mean or
anything like that or is he possibly
just saying something about maybe about
personal responsibility that kind of
stuff that's usually what'll get you
canceled these days well anyway andrew
tate he was cancelled on all of these
things
and he went on tucker carlson about a
week ago to discuss his banning andrew
tate is a former kickboxer who's built
up a truly enormous following on social
media until a couple months ago we'd
never heard of him and then the other
day
virtually every tech company on the
planet banned him not just his presence
but also his ability to conduct business
on the internet he was taken off
instagram tick tock facebook youtube all
of it
then they started telling you that not
only was he not allowed to talk but you
weren't allowed to like him because he
was an incredibly bad person i don't
really feel like i've exposed anything
like i'm truly
not a very political person this is the
first time someone's experienced this
level of ban i'm not particularly
right-wing i don't vote i mean i
obviously have my own personal views but
they didn't ban me for that
they banned me simply because
i had large swaths of the population
agreeing to very traditional masculine
values
teenage men and young and young men 20
30 22 23 24
were looking up to me and aspiring to be
like me i have a very traditionally
masculine life i have fast cars and a
big house and a lot of money and a
beautiful girlfriend and they thought
they thought this was very very
threatening and for some reason they
decided that it's better if they
annihilate me from the internet and
replace me with somebody who's more
aligned with
whatever they're trying to purport
okay so what's super interesting about
this and i would welcome you to google
this guy and try to find out what his
crazy
dangerous evil views are is you can tell
even just in that you know 30 seconds
that he's talking there this guy is not
a hater he's somebody that's living his
life
he is proud of how he lives he believes
that men are men women are women that
personal responsibility means something
that success is not evil and then the
way they do the coordinated
assassination now you remember the
coordinate assassination this is what
they did to alex jones this is what they
did to donald trump when it's not like
oh instagram just has an internal
meeting and they're like okay we're
going to get rid of them but they all
figure out a way to do it within days
and not only can they do it to people
but of course they can also do it to
websites remember parlor
so we know that this sort of thing
happens and i this morning as i was
doing cardio i was googling andrew tate
trying to find all the hateful things
that he said and i couldn't find it so
it's interesting because now this guy
has become sort of the center of the
firestorm he's got rogan talking about
it now he's got everybody talking about
well what's going on here what are the
views that you're not allowed to have on
these big tech platforms well here are
some of his views tell us what your
message is to young men
yeah so i think that being a man is very
very difficult
i think that men's issues are largely
overlooked
the people in charge of the world
pretend to care but when somebody who's
champion champion championing men's
issues like myself comes forward and
finally manages to garner huge
percentiles of the public support i'm
silenced so they're not really
interested in men's issues and there's a
lot of young men growing up today that
feel very disaffected they feel
invisible the agendas that are being
forced down their throats are not
agendas they align with or they feel
affinity to or agendas they want
and i basically just say to men look
it's a very hard life you're gonna need
to get up work hard go to the gym strong
body is a strong mind you're going to
have to reject
listening blindly to everything you're
told reject the slave mind think for
yourself get a strong network of
brothers work aside them don't tolerate
low quality people in your life which
means don't tolerate men who just smoke
drugs and play video games or men who
are disloyal or dishonest by extension
don't tolerate women or girlfriends who
are disloyal or dishonest and try and
build and create a reality full of high
quality people in which you can resist
the programming that the matrix tries to
infl uh influence you with and grow up
true
man does some of that sound kind of
familiar kind of jordan peterson he kind
of obvious like live an honest life take
care of yourself realize that it's hard
out there but it's on you to figure
things out and in some ways that is the
scariest message to the machine the
machine wants you compromised and fat
and watching porn all the time and
eating unhealthy and not doing anything
for yourself and constantly needing more
of it so the message of self-empowerment
whether you're empowering men or women
is this most dangerous thing that is the
most dangerous thing for the people that
want to control you and if you thought
that some of that
about about men and the importance of
men is
is sort of familiar we have had this
video waiting i saw this on instagram a
couple months back and i sent it to
phoenix and i said there is going to be
a day when this video is going to fit
perfectly in this in this show i want to
find that day it's just going to present
itself well today is the day here is an
incredible side by side of jordan
peterson being asked about the
importance of men and whether whether
it's easy to be a man or not it's okay
to be a man
it's not okay it's necessary
what the hell are we going to do without
men
you look around the city here you see
all these buildings go up these men
they're doing impossible things they're
under the streets working on the sewers
they're up on the power lines in the
storms and the rain they're keeping this
impossible infrastructure functioning
this thing that works in miraculous
manner
they work themselves
to death
and often literally
and the gratitude for that is so sorely
lacking especially among the people who
should be most grateful failing to
understand entirely that there's a
massive infrastructure of unbelievably
hardworking
solidly laboring working-class men
breaking themselves in half on a regular
basis
making sure that everything that always
breaks works
and so a little gratitude for that is in
order
pretty good
pretty good you think that that guy
who's got the cockroaches climbing all
over him god only knows what kind of
toxins he's breathing in and has been
doing that probably for years and years
you think he's got male privilege white
male privilege white christian male
privilege or is he just a guy trying to
survive
it actually reminded me of something
while i was off the grid we were doing
some construction at the house and we
had a problem with the septic tank and i
called this company and a guy shows up
at the door
uh probably maybe a few years older than
me he was literally and i mean literally
covered in feces the guy's job is to get
into the septic tank he climbs into your
septic tanks you know what a septic tank
is i mean it's basically all of the all
of the poop and all of the stuff of your
house
uh he climbs in them and he cleans them
out and this guy he comes i mean it was
all over his glasses he was in his hair
he had just come from a job the guy
couldn't have possibly been nicer with
the smile on his face
saying heard you just had a kid
congratulations blah blah blah how can i
help you
um and it's like man this is these are
the people that we're being told are the
worst
people in
society and it seems to me that uh
andrew tate's message which is pretty
similar to jordan peterson's message
which is which is just similar to a
message that is an obvious truth that we
all knew that life is hard that you
should take responsibility for yourself
imagine taking care of yourself how what
a crazy idea imagine surrounding
yourself with good honest people now
it's funny because as you guys know and
we do this every day it's like we're
around politicians and media people who
lie to us every day so what would scare
them the most it's obvious and it's the
truth right so
where i want to link this to back to the
censorship thing uh is that
jordan i just played that video jordan
he's been getting censored for a long
time you guys all know about the twitter
thing and much more uh but now something
that he's been warning against for years
compelled language related to pronouns
is actually putting a teacher in jail in
ireland like it's actually happening he
was warned about it six years ago
everyone said he's a crackpot
you know blah blah blah turns out
actually the truth uh before we get to
that let me talk about raycon real quick
you know lately i've been listening to a
lot of fleetwood mac and that jordan
peterson guy and a lot of yacht rock and
it's been great one reason it's been
great well because i use my raycon
wireless earbuds to do it raycon's
everyday earbuds look
feel and sound better than ever with
optimized gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit these earbuds are so
comfortable and they will not budge
trust me raycons offer three sound
profiles to match what you're listening
to plus noise isolation and awareness
mode so you can choose to be immersed in
sound or able to hear your surroundings
when you need to i love using my raycons
when i'm walking my dog clyde on walks
in the iguana fest infested
neighborhoods of miami raycons give you
eight hours of play time and 32 hour
battle battery life and when you need a
charge it's super easy and you can do it
wirelessly plus there's a huge selling
point with raycons you get the same
quality audio as other premium audio
brands but at half the price yes it's
true i've seen people talking about
their recons falling three stories
getting lost in rain and snowstorms and
still working afterwards that must be
why they have over forty nine thousand
five star reviews check out raycon's
wireless earbuds my guess is that you're
going to want to leave them a five star
review too go to raycon dot com slash
reuben today to get 15 off your raycon
order that's by
raycon.com ruben to get 15 percent off
by recon dot com reuben and now back to
me okay so let's uh let's continue on
the theme here how is it that saying
basic truths
has now become not only dangerous but
something worthy of canceling people
well you may remember a couple months
ago before i was off the grid uh jordan
peterson was suspended on twitter he has
been permanently banned on twitter he
ain't on the twitter anymore god bless
him uh because he said something about
what was known as ellen page she was an
actress in x-men i thought she was
pretty good she was in a couple other
movies what she was in juneau she was in
inception she was a pretty good actress
now she is elliot page and she
transitioned i suppose and you must
refer to her with her pronouns or you
will be demolished and destroyed anyway
jordan had tweet about her he got banned
i screenshot that thing i then got
banned i'm back he's gone okay there you
go but jordan is not taking it lying
down he put up a spectacular video
yesterday he's back on tour in europe
right now but he put this up i think
it's just in the last few hours uh
talking directly to twitter ceo parag
agrawal
take a look at this portion
i was banned from your platform without
anything other than a generic and
self-serving low resolution explanation
two
that my appeal of that ban was ignored
even though my repetition of the
aforesaid behavior was noted and acted
upon within hours if not minutes
three
that your company's reasons for banning
and manipulating or regulating the
behavior of your users are utterly
opaque ineffectual and
self-contradictory
for
that your own security personnel and
potential investors or even purchasers
of your company have been properly
scared off by the chaos that reigns
under your authority
five that you take to yourself the moral
propriety necessary
to continue censoring a former president
of the united states even as a critical
election approaches without knowing at
all whether or not you are making even
the situation under him that you object
to worse instead of better and have
absolutely no reliable data pertaining
to that possibility and finally
six
that your careless sensorious behavior
and enabling of the anonymous
machiavellian narcissists and
psychopaths who inhabit the twitter
troll underworld is warping and
dementing the entire domain of public
discourse
hey what you mean say it clearly pretty
good jordan peterson uh so that is in
essence it's an open letter to the
twitter ceo now the twitter ceo of
course will not respond uh we also know
that twitter is now in this legal fight
with elon musk over they are now trying
to force him to buy the thing right
remember at first they didn't want to
buy the thing they were going to take
this poison pill the board was really
afraid that he was going to buy it and
create a free speech zone so they were
going to in essence destroy the entire
company then enough of the shareholders
were like whoa whoa whoa whoa when the
world's richest man wants to buy the
company at a premium price we want to
sell so then they decided to sell then
elon basically was like okay well i just
need to look at some numbers here and
does this all make sense and how many
bots are here and is this whole thing
fake i mean i am buying a business here
uh and now he found out that a whole
bunch of it's fake there are there are
uh analysts data analysts that believe
that up to 80
80 of the twitter attraction might be
fake elon was willing to say i'll buy it
at five percent fake uh but eighty
percent's a bridge too far but anyway
uh the the twitter ceo obviously is not
going to respond to this and isn't it
interesting i i often think about this
you know we're all on let's say twitter
or you use gmail or you're on facebook
or whatever you can't get anyone from
these companies on the phone have any of
you guys ever gotten anyone from these
companies on the phone spoke to anyone
at these companies isn't that
interesting like would you buy a car
from a company that you could never
speak to someone on the phone maybe you
could get an emailed response but
usually just get a form letter maybe you
could get a robot in a chat but yet we
all go on gmail
we all have the suite of google products
run our businesses on these things and
there is literally nobody to talk to at
these companies do you think something
strange is going on here well in any
event jordan is still fighting and you
must still fight and we
well i don't i don't like making these
things about me but i am somewhat in the
in the center of these things so in case
you forgot i was then suspended because
i defended jordan all i did was actually
screenshot what he was defended for
here's a little bit recapping that uh
before we get to what's going on today
now uh conservative pundit dave rubin
revealed that he'd been suspended from
twitter for merely tweeting news about
famed canadian psychology professor and
philosopher jordan peterson's own
suspension from twitter in the statement
reuben wrote i have been suspended by
twitter for posting a screenshot of
jordan peterson's tweet which got he
himself suspended while it is unclear
how i broke their terms of service he
continued it is clear that they are
breaking their fiduciary responsibility
to their shareholders by letting a bunch
of woke activists run the company
reuben's offending tweet from june 29th
read the insanity continues at twitter
jordan peterson has been suspended for
this tweet about ellen page he just told
me he will never delete the tweet reuben
added paging elon musk to the end of his
tweet hoping uh
hoping to get the attention of the
billionaire ceo who's seeking to buy
twitter and reorganize the company to
better protect free speech okay so why
am i doing all this why am i recapping
this it's not just so i can read my own
tweets again
what is happening in the world right now
we all know it we all know that there as
jordan just uh mentioned there are
midterm elections coming they've still
got trump booted off twitter they have
no idea what the ramifications all of
the of those things are we know that
zuckerberg admitted that the
administration and the intelligence
services contacted him before the last
election to say that there was something
crazy going on and they should maybe
suppress some things and then they
suppress the laptop story and all of
these things so this is all been going
on but guess what there were some people
warning about this for a long time and
i'm actually proud to say that i was one
of the people warning about it but i
certainly wasn't the first and perhaps
censorship at this level even before big
tech was involved has been going on
all time right from the printing press
forward it possibly has been happening
now i want to flash to something this
was a real time work when we watched
this thing this morning
this is my first ever interview with
jordan peterson in november
of 2016. i did not even have a studio
yet i was just we i had just moved into
my new house we were about to build the
studio i didn't even know who jordan
peterson was really we had a very shaky
internet because we had just moved in a
bunch of people online kept saying you
know there's this guy jordan peterson
and he's super interesting and he's
fighting this government censorship in
canada and it's about gender ideology
and i thought okay let's just talk to
him there was this bill c-16 thing
coming and it was like all right what is
going on here let me talk to this guy uh
and do you think perhaps that jordan was
warning about things that now are coming
true six years ago take a look so for
people that don't know your story what
has sort of put you in the news over the
last couple of months
it's actually quite astounding because
you are in canada which is a place that
has a strong tradition of free speech so
for people that have no idea what's
going on with you uh can you just lay
out the the basics of what's transpired
over the last couple months
yeah well there's a there's some new
legislation that's pending at the
federal level called bill c-16 and bill
c-16 adds gender identity and gender
expression to the list of protected
categories under the canadian human
rights code canadian human rights act
and uh
also adds transgressions against those
categories people who are in those
categories
uh to the hate speech provisions of the
criminal code
so it's it's very very punitive
legislation and that in itself is is
is somewhat appalling although it's not
obvious why but
there's similar legislation already in
many provinces in canada
which equivalent to the state level
and
uh the
there's a requirement that that
originated in ontario
for people to use
preferred what their what are called
preferred pronouns to address someone
and as far as i can tell
by reading over the legislation
failure to use someone's preferred
pronouns is now a hate crime in canada
okay so six years ago jordan was warning
that canada was pushing this bill c-16
and that people could potentially be
fined
or jailed because they did not use
someone's preferred pronoun now we know
in the last six years the he she they
them zizer all of this nonsense has
burst forth everywhere
corporations are forcing people to put
their pronouns in things if you
misgender someone you'll be canceled or
kicked off big tech blah blah blah but
when he was warning about that and i
even remember uh in that in that
conversation that we were having i
remember thinking like this this is all
overblown like this isn't going to be
something that's going to really turn
into something and i quickly realized
that that wasn't the case uh but now uh
a teacher in ireland is in jail for
misgendering ireland a western country
in europe right a country that is
supposed to be based in freedom and have
free speech some of the stuff we have
here well the warning that jordan was
making about canada it is now happening
in the west and if you think that it's
going to stop in ireland uh well i got a
bridge to sell you so we have much more
on that in just a second let me talk to
you about real estate agents i trust you
know buying or selling a home is already
one of the most stressful things you can
do and it can be 10 times worse if
you're not working with the right agent
generally speaking our homes are our
biggest investment which is a ton of
responsibility and you need an agent who
takes that seriously which is why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
they work with only the best agents in
every market they do their homework
talking to every agent before inviting
them to join their network and here's a
big one they only work with full-time
pros no part-time or inexperienced
agents their team makes the introduction
then follows you through the buying or
selling process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records are the best sellers
in their field they're part of this
audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
just go over to real estate agents
itrust.com today and provide them with
some information their team will contact
you to make an introduction to their
preferred agent in your town you move to
florida you live happily ever after okay
there you go so
six years ago jordan peterson
is warning about bill c-16 he is warning
that governments are going to compel
speech meaning punish you if you don't
use speech if you don't use words and
terms that they want you to use so we
you guys know all about the big tech
version of this but now western
governments are doing this as well here
is an incredible story coming out of
ireland ireland we've got some info from
the daily mail
a teacher who refused to use
gender-neutral pronouns for a
transgender student has been sent to
mount joy prison for contempt of court
enoch burke was arrested yesterday
morning for breaching a court order not
to teach at his westmeath school or be
physically present there after judge
michael quinn made his ruling mr burke
said it is insanity that i will be led
from this courtroom to a place of
incarceration but i will not give up my
christian beliefs
counsel for wilson's hospital schools
board of management said it was with a
heavy heart that it sought mr burke's
committal to prison but she said her
client had been left with no choice as
mr burke continued to attend the school
despite the court order which it had
obtained last week the dispute began
over his refusal to address a
transitioning student as they rather
than he as requested by the student and
their parents in may and agreed to by
the church of ireland school
this escalated to his suspension on the
day before the start of the autumn term
pending the outcome of a disciplinary
process he had refused to remain away
from the school on paid leave for that
suspension the court heard and would sit
in an empty classroom declaring that he
was there to work okay so it is
happening
it is happening where are the free
speech activists on the left where is
the aclu where are those good liberals
who should be screaming about it
screaming about this there is a man in
jail in ireland because he refused to
use someone's pronouns
and there will be people in jail in
canada because they refuse to do it and
guess what they will try to figure out a
way to do it here in the united states
thank god for that first amendment
although i have no doubt that the blue
states like cali in new york will figure
out ways to to trample on that
but
what do we have to do what do we have to
do if we're here in the united states
well we really have to expose this
nonsense as it's coming i wanted to show
you a video that we showed you once a
couple of months back this is senator
rand paul from kentucky calling out dhs
secretary alexander mayorkas uh on his
federal government big tech
disinformation board remember this they
were going to have a disinformation
board
which quickly fell apart because enough
of us fought against it and then of
course the people who were in charge of
the disinformation board said that we
were sharing this information about them
yada yada but rand paul has been leading
on this that the government
should not have these organizations
because it in itself is an affront to
free speech how do you propose that
you're going to have an office of
disinformation governance
if you see the problem in even
determining what is disinformation oh
senator because
our work is not
focused on disinformation writ large
where we the department of homeland
security become involved
is when there's a connectivity between
disinformation
and threats
to the security of the homeland well
that's what the russians might be
considered that you mentioned the
russians the other day when you tried to
pivot away from this being about
censorship through social media and what
we do through us customs and border
protection
is actually communicate via social media
and other channels that that is false
that we do apply title 42. so let's say
there's russian disinformation as well
are you going to take to social media
and broadcast that people are
broadcasting something incorrect about
what do you think is russian
disinformation
senator let me emphasize you said the
other day russians and now you're saying
not so much the russians you're saying
the cartels no i'm not no i'm not
senator you're you're mischaracterizing
my state then what are you going to do
if there's russian disinformation you're
going to broadcast something on social
media
okay so do you see the package that
we're putting together here big tech
apparently doesn't want you
talking about personal responsibility
and understanding that it is your life
and you have some autonomy over it the
government seemingly doesn't want you to
be able to say what you think about
what's going on in politics they want to
be able to have boards of disinformation
i mean thankfully this thing crumbled
but they want their word to be
the truth right and their word is
usually not the truth they have lied
about virtually everything do we have to
go through the two years of covid right
and science and all that but speaking of
the two years of covet in science uh
remember when anthony fauci said an
attack on him is an attack on the truth
it's very dangerous chuck because a lot
of what you're seeing as attacks on me
quite frankly are attacks on science
because all of the things that i have
spoken about
consistently from the very beginning
have been fundamentally based on science
sometimes those things were inconvenient
truths for people and there was pushback
against me so if you are trying to do
you know get at me
as a public health official and a
scientist you're really attacking not
only dr anthony fauci you're attacking
science and anybody that looks
at what's going on
clearly sees that you have to be asleep
not to see that that is what's going on
science and the truth are being attacked
he is the truth
he is science now let's see if any of
that's true i made a couple notes while
he was talking there he says all things
that i spoke about that these were these
were the true things that he spoke about
they were inconvenient for some people
but they're true well actually uh
lockdowns which he was for turns out
they don't work and there was actually
no data to even ever prove that they
could possibly work and they've also led
to all sorts of secondary problems you
guys know it between depression and
alcoholism and all sorts of health
problems because people didn't get out
and vitamin d deficiency and all that
masks we know the masks didn't work
right they just simply do not work and
it was obvious from the beginning you
put on one of these crappy masks you've
got air coming out this way air coming
out this way people literally couldn't
hear you when you're talking the mask so
that was my favorite one when everyone
you'd be talking to somebody you're both
in mass they can't hear you you're
mumbled you take the mask down to talk
to them that was always a good one he
lied about that he lied about kids in
school
because he was all for closing down the
school and pretending that kids were all
going to die of covid and that just
never happened he also lied and he said
that vaccines work and vaccines do not
work as you know they basically
redefined the definition of vaccines and
now they're telling us just yesterday
they started telling us that they wanted
to basically be like the flu shot where
you'll just get a covet 19 vaccine every
year so they lie about everything and
they do it under the auspices of big
tech that promotes their lies but if you
expose their lies you will be
taken out and this is a giant collusion
between zuckerberg and fouchy and this
administration and a whole bunch more
people we'll get to that just a sec real
quick guys are you watching on the blaze
you should because as you guys know i
was gone in august and larry elder gave
me a rundown of all that happened when i
was away and it was a ton was i
surprised to hear that zuckerberg helped
the fbi aka the government manage the
hunter biden laptop story no not really
were you was i surprised to hear gavin
newsom is continuing to destroy
california with near laughable measures
no not really were you
think of msnbc like california and blaze
tv like florida or texas you'd have to
be crazy to believe california will see
and admit to the error of their ways for
the same reasons you'd have to be crazy
to think msnbc will ever be fair and
report news without a rabid left-wing
agenda that's why blaze tv matters it's
the media network for americans who
actually love the country is founded
it's where people can say what needs to
be said without the fear of censorship
you know how strongly i believe in free
speech blaze tv supports free speech the
way the founding fathers intended so
this week and this week only blaze tv is
offering a 20 discount off the first
year of your blaze tv subscription we're
heading into the midterms you're going
to want to
you're going to want news from a network
that isn't run by democrats or the
spouses of democrats use promo code
ruben 20 for 20 off your first year
subscription to blaze tv it's time to
normalize free speech okay
we've been putting quite a puzzle
together on this uh program today i
think you're seeing that big tech and
big government are all for censoring
people and it's not just censoring mean
scary people who happen to be orange or
are named alex jones it's anyone right
this andrew tate story it's anyone who's
just saying something that might put a
little power back into your hand that's
what they are going for well how long
has this been going on well this is this
is really extraordinary the daily caller
uh got some info here on the close
relationship between mark zuckerberg of
facebook and dr anthony fauci mr science
facebook founder mark zuckerberg gave dr
anthony fauci his personal cell phone
number in march of 2020 before facebook
began censoring alleged misinformation
about the covet 19 pandemic new court
documents reveal documents revealed
during the discovery had shed new light
on the biden administration's role in
social media censorship during the
pandemic zuckerberg's move to give fauci
his phone number demonstrated the
intention to have further communications
according to the plaintiffs in a suit
against president joe biden regarding
censorship of information during the
pandemic
facebook founder mark zuckerberg gave
anthony fauci his personal sell no cell
in march 2020 before facebook began
censoring alleged misinformation about
the covid19 pandemic new court documents
reveal so what's really fascinating
about this uh we're going to show you in
just a second is as you know uh over the
last couple weeks mark zuckerberg went
on rogan he went on rogan and admitted
that they censored things related to the
hunter biden story so do you think when
he gave fouchy his number in march of
2020 that was the beginning of this
whole thing do you think some texts were
sent back and forth do you think he
liked being buddies with the guy who is
the truth he is the truth he is the
science and maybe started doing things
on his platform that would make him and
the government happy
rather than doing what was truthful and
honest well in case you forgot how he uh
is a big fan of censorship here is
zuckerberg on rogan uh talking about
hunter biden like there was a lot of
attention on twitter
during the election because of the
hunter biden laptop story the new yeah
yeah so you guys censored that as well
so we took a different path than twitter
um i mean basically the background here
is the fbi i think basically came to us
some some folks on our team it was like
hey
um
just so you know like you should be on
high alert there was
we we thought there was a lot of russian
propaganda in the 2016 election we have
it on notice that basically there's
about to be some kind of dump of of um
uh
that's similar to that so just be
vigilant so our protocol is different
from twitter's what twitter did is they
said you can't share this at all um we
didn't do that what we do is we have um
if something is reported to us as
potentially
um misinformation important
misinformation we we also have this
third party fact-checking program
because we don't want to be deciding
what's true and false and for the
i think it was
five or seven days when it was basically
being
um
being determined whether it was false
the distribution on facebook was
decreased but people were still allowed
to share it so you could still share it
you could still consume it when i say
the distribution has decreased it got
shared how does that work basically the
ranking and news feed was a little bit
less so
fewer people saw it than would have
otherwise so it definitely by what
percentage i don't know off the top my
head but it's it's it's meaningful
i mean it's incredible so distribution
was decreased at first he says
uh distribution was decreased it was a
little bit then he says it was
meaningful at the end so you could share
it you could share the hunter biden
laptop story but if you share it and no
one's around to see it have you shared
it at all if a tree falls in the forest
you get it you see what they did so what
he's saying and he also says this thing
we don't want to we don't want to be in
charge of what's true and false so we go
to third party fact checkers well
surprise surprise all of their
third-party track factor ch fact
checkers
fact [ __ ] are uh
they're all we know this they're all
left-wing activist organizations right
they're not going to anyone
right-leaning to ask what a fact is or
isn't so they're telling you
that oh we don't censor we let you post
things we just don't let people see it
right and this is what shadow banning is
this is on twitter when you know right i
used to be able to tweet out i could put
a picture i'd you know i could put a
picture of alf and a emoji of a banana
and it would get 10 000 retweets and now
people just don't see the tweets anymore
so they haven't censored me i'm still
tweeting there's just nobody there to
see it so why does this all matter okay
so let's try to bring this thing full
circle there are more and more people
seeing it
rogan and his audience are getting it
you guys are getting it there are more
platforms out there whether it's rumble
or it's locals we're all realizing that
they are they are censoring us that they
are recommending videos to change our
opinions they're not letting us see
things like it's huge it's a huge thing
like like we're we are in this cave with
this limited information and if we would
just walk outside i think we would see
much more but what do they try to do
to you if you dare talk about these
things well for some people like andrew
tate they'll kick you off all the
platforms uh for other people like rogan
they will do their best to kick you off
but in his case he's almost too big to
be kicked off like it actually might be
the one that breaks the camel's back you
guys remember this back in february 22.
remember there was that two-week stretch
where everybody was saying joe rogan was
a racist because a bunch of left-wing
activists selectively edited videos of
him saying the n-word even though he was
never saying in a pejorative manner to
make it seem like he was a racist well
then what happened the mainstream media
because the mainstream media is in on it
with big tech and with the government
what did they do well they churn up the
hate to see if they could get joe rogan
fired here is now fired cnn anchor brian
stelter and soon to be fired cnn
correspondent jim acosta
talking about why rogan should be
censored the video is an edited
compilation of different podcast
episodes brian uh what is joe rogan now
saying
he is now apologizing and we're gonna
find out if that's enough for spotify
the company that has an exclusive
distribution deal with him jim this is
all coming to light because of the
recent controversy about anti-vaccine
rhetoric on rogan's podcast some artists
uh decided to quit the service one of
them india re pointed out this video
this compilation video and pointed out
that the language rogan has used around
race in the past is just as or maybe
even more problematic than his rhetoric
about vaccines that would be enough to
put anybody out of a job i mean to me i
i it seems untenable to have that kind
of video surface that kind of
compilation surface and keep one's job
okay so it's actually great watching
that video now and of course that was
from a few months ago now knowing that
stelter has since been fired because
nobody was listening to him and nobody
trusted him but do you see what they
were doing there that was a mainstream
news organization
in essence doing a segment for one
purpose and the one purpose was to get
joe rogan fired because more people are
paying attention to joe rogan than they
are paying attention to those two clowns
what acosta said there at the end anyone
should have been fired for this and he's
talking about this n-word thing rogan
never said the n-word to be racist but
of course you get all the cowards of the
universe come out against him you andrew
yang
a real brave guy that one is he tweeted
support of rogan after that saying he's
not racist then a few weirdos on twitter
went after gang and then he deleted it i
mean it's just so incredible how people
respond to this uh to this mob but in
essence they were doing that not because
they are anti-racist and not because
they were uh even because they were
pro-vaccine what they are is pro their
monopoly on information so big tech
wants a monopoly on information the
government wants a monopoly on
information the media wants a monopoly
on information and all of us those of us
that speak freely and try to work things
through and understand that things are
messy on the sides and you're not just
supposed to listen to the man just
because he tells you something we are
the threats to those things now what's
interesting about this
is that although they tried to get rogan
kicked off spotify that did not work uh
although spotify does have a bit of a
spotty record no pun intended when it
comes to free speech this is uh from ms
this is from nbc uh when when uh rogan
did not get the boot fully spotify ceo
daniel elk sent a letter to company
employees sunday apologizing for the
controversy surrounding joe rogan but
also backing the podcasters say he did
not believe that silencing joe is the
answer the company was reported to have
taken down about 70 episodes of the joe
rogan experience over the weekend on
saturday rogan publicly apologized
apologized for instances when he used
the n-word in past podcasts in a letter
to spotify employees which a company
spokesperson sent to nbc news x said the
comments rogan made in past podcasts do
not represent the values of this company
eck wrote that spotify has been talking
to rogan and his team about some of the
content on his show including his
history of using some racially uh
racially insensitive language following
these discussions and his own
reflections he chose to remove a number
of episodes from spotify said he also
issued his own apology over the weekend
so what's interesting about this is
before rogan signed the deal and it's
it's a couple hundred million bucks it's
a lot of money and then he left cali
because he didn't want to pay taxes on
that good move dude um he they had
immediately taken off some episodes
before all this happened when the
catalog moved from youtube to spotify
they had already taken off some now
they're saying that rogan was willing to
take those off but the point is and this
is why linking this back to where we
started on the show this video of him
from a couple days ago where he's
talking about how rumble isn't going to
censor it's like it's obvious that any
of the spotify is not ultimately going
to stand with him youtube is not
ultimately going to stand with me
twitter is not ultimately going to stand
with jordan peterson and none of these
things are really in it for you they're
in it for you as long as you give them
your attention your eyeballs the clicks
and all of those things so now let's
really tie a nice i think we've tied
quite a little package here but really
let's tighten the knot on this one how
does a censorship work well here's joe
rogan you made a really good point you
said the thing is if you sense yourself
just one percent you say i'll just
censor myself one percent that's what
they want i'm going to make them happy
and then they're just going to keep
moving it they're just going to keep
moving it forward moving forward moving
the goals and providing you with more
money and giving you more things but
keep moving in a certain direction and
if you keep giving into it
they're going to have a hold of you now
what's interesting he's talking to alex
jones there could you hear alex jones
gruffness on the side uh but his point
is if you give in a little bit they'll
give you more and then you'll just keep
going now he got he gave in a little bit
and got a lot of money uh but to his
credit so this is not an attack on joe
rogan he's still talking about
censorship now he's talking about the
importance of rumble and these
alternative platforms so he does still
get it right like so so you can we all
do things we all have pressures we all
want to make some money we all have
families we all have a life we want to
live so it's just interesting that we're
all in this game uh and then this video
which we've shown you a couple times i i
really just love this one because it's
the ever encroaching uh move of
censorship it's they don't do it
overnight none of these bad things
happen overnight and that's why i showed
you the jordan peterson video from six
years ago it's like we don't forget
where we were
because that's how if you if you know
that then maybe you could look to the
future and see where we're headed uh
jordan's been warning about it for a
long time just don't understand how it
gets to the point where things get to
terrible places one tiny step at a time
you know if i encroach i if i encroach
on you and i'm sophisticated about it
i'm going to encroach two millimeters
i'm going to encroach right to the point
where you stop start to protest then i'm
going to stop then i'm going to wait
then you're going to calm down then i'm
going to encroach again right to the
point where you protest then i'm gonna
stop then i'm gonna wait and i'm just
gonna do that forever and before you
know it you're gonna be back three miles
from where you started and you'll have
done it one step at a time and then
you'll go oh how'd i get here and the
answer was well
i pushed you a little farther than you
should have gone and you agreed and so
then i pushed you a little farther than
you should have gone again and you
agreed and if anybody's interested in
this sort of process and this is a
horrifying book if you want to read
about how this process works you can
read a book called
ordinary men
well so who's guilty here right i would
say that we all need only look in a
mirror and it's all of us right when
they took out alex jones whether you
thought alex jones was a good guy or a
nut bag or anything else
they saw oh we pushed these people
but nobody really did anything right
then they took out the sitting president
of the united states
you'd think that that might be enough
but they pushed us and most of us just
stayed on these platforms well now there
are answers right now there is rumble
now there are is locals there are some
answers coming but they are going to
keep moving uh and i would love to uh
you know i always tell you guys i don't
really look in the youtube comments
because i'm focused on locals and
you know i just have a limited amount of
time during the day but i know people
are not you're clicking subscribe on our
videos you're clicking the notification
bell and i know you're not seeing it i
know the recommended videos are a mess
all of those things i know you're not
seeing my tweets i would i will read the
comments on today's live stream uh and i
would love people to just share your
thoughts on what's going on here what
are you seeing and not seeing and
everything else
but fortunately
i am not someone that just talks about
these things i actually do some things
that's why i built locals that's why we
merged with rumble i hope you will watch
these live streams instead of many of
you are still watching on on youtube
obviously most of you are but i hope
you'll go over to rumble.com
ruben report and subscribe there and you
will actually see our videos that there
is no threat of censorship or anything
else okay let's get to some comments and
then we got a great cold clothes for you
ek says how does dave get his hair to
perfectly swoop like that that is the
perfect swoop uh a little uh
i could have could have got that part in
a little bit better over there uh there
are there are two hairsprays that are
involved
and there is i'm fairly certain that my
insides are being preserved by whatever
chemical is in the hairspray because if
i do it at the right time of day i can
see the amount of stuff that's just
floating around it can't be can't be
great for you but i try to drink enough
water to get it out of my system but i
use a dry texturizing spray that gives
it the lift then a little super fine
hairspray just to lightly keep it
in place uh patriot says i want to see
dave wearing raycons and walking in
iguana
you know what
i will try daphne we will okay we're
going to get out to the backyard and see
if we can make that happen because we've
got a lot of iguanas out there actually
my one problem in florida at the moment
i don't know if you guys have seen this
i got a lot of iguana poop around the
pool the iguanas i think are taking dips
at night with the frogs and they they
poop right on the ledge of the pool so
i'm constantly cleaning up iguana poop
but i guess that is the price you have
to pay for freedom uh compared to say
california where people don't have
electricity yeah what are you going to
do america mom says is rumble public yet
i really want to put my money where my
mouth is i would recommend you just
google cfvi
and their their spac is
changing i don't know how much i can get
into it here but uh check take a look at
that um
part one of my interview with jared
kushner is up on rumble and it is also
on locals at least or it is also on
youtube at least for now the full thing
is up ad free on locals and finally we
have a cold clothes for you that's sort
of unrelated to the show today but i
just thought it was funny have a nice
day and you know how much
you know how much i'm going to do with
the deficit this year not much time to
do with the dev this year
jeremy dude with the deaf this
[Music]
this year how much